[Música]
en el Día Internacional del trabajo
miles de personas marcharon en todo el
mundo para exigir mejoras laborales en
América Latina los presidentes de
izquierda se dieron un baño de masas en
Colombia Gustavo Petro reivindicó su
propuesta de reforma laboral y Lula
anunció el aumento del salario mínimo en
Brasil
la secretaría del tesoro de Estados
Unidos Pide a los líderes del senado y
de la cámara de representantes aumentar
el techo de la deuda lo antes posible y
advierte que el estado podría quedarse
sin liquidez en junio
el gobierno de Brasil anuncia que va a
reforzar la lucha contra la minería
ilegal en territorios indígenas este fin
de semana un operativo policial acabó
con la vida de cuatro mineros ilegales
en la reserva de la comunidad yanomami
en la misma área donde un hombre
indígena murió a manos de Mineros el
sábado
Bienvenidos a esta edición informativa
dedicada a las noticias más relevantes
del continente americano iniciamos en
América Latina porque en el Día
Internacional del trabajo la región se
sumó a la reivindicaciones globales en
pro de los derechos de las personas
trabajadoras Pese a que el izquierdismo
gobierna en la gran mayoría de países de
Suramérica las desigualdades y la falta
de derechos laborales Siguen sin estar
resueltas marinas ardiña con los
detalles
un día de reivindicaciones globales
desde Argentina Colombia miles de
latinoamericanos salieron a las calles
en el Día Internacional del trabajo los
más recientes mandatarios izquierdistas
lanzaron mensajes de movilización social
reforma salariales y pensionales con el
presidente colombiano Gustavo Petro que
presiona al congreso para que apoye sus
polémicas reformas sociales laboral o la
de la salud pueblos
trabajado en la primera línea de la
lucha por las transformaciones de
Colombia en La Vanguardia del
progresismo de este país
Los invito a estar en la vanguardia de
la historia de Colombia su homólogo
brasileño Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva con
grego a miles de personas en Sao Paulo
donde confirmó un reajuste del salario
mínimo una de sus promesas de campaña
así como un incremento del sueldo mínimo
para trabajadores jubilados y
pensionistas
hemos instituido una vez más Un aumento
Real del salario mínimo por encima de la
inflación
[Aplausos]
a partir de ahora además de la inflación
el trabajador recibirá el crecimiento
medio del pib
en Venezuela donde el salario mínimo
cayó a 5 dólares por la inflación
cientos de trabajadores salieron a las
calles para exigir mejoras en sus
condiciones laborales mientras el
mandatario Nicolás duro prometió Un
aumento del cesta ticket un mono de
alimentación a 40 dólares y del Bono de
guerra económica al sector de la
educación jubilados públicos y
pensionistas a 20 dólares como adiciones
salariales en Sudamérica la mayoría de
gobiernos son de izquierda pero los
desafíos en derechos para los
trabajadores en especial para las
mujeres y jóvenes siguen siendo amplios
debido en parte a las altas tasas de
informalidad laboral en la región
vamos ahora a Estados Unidos donde el
próximo 11 de mayo expira el decreto de
emergencia sanitaria por la pandemia de
covid-19 como consecuencia la
administración dejará de exigir la
vacunación contra el coronavirus a los
empleados y contratistas federales y a
Los viajeros internacionales según
anunció este lunes la casa blanca
recordemos que la vacunación obligatoria
en Estados Unidos Fue una medida que
polarizó extremadamente el país
y seguimos en Estados Unidos porque la
secretaria del tesoro envió una carta a
los líderes de la cámara de
representantes y del senado en que los
advertía de la necesidad de aumentar el
techo de la deuda es decir la cantidad
legal en que puede endeudarse el estado
un límite que se encuentra ahora en los
31,4 billones de dólares yelen advirtió
que si los congresistas no elevan el
monto la administración pública entraría
en un impago el primero de junio la
cámara dominada Por los republicanos
aceptó Elevar el techo en 1,5 billones
respecto al anterior a cambio presionan
a biden para que recorte los gastos
públicos y aunque el presidente de la
cámara baja Kevin mccarthy afirma que
cumplieron su deber Joe biden reiteró
este lunes que es necesario que el
senado lo suba más
lo más inmediato que podemos hacer es
garantizar la dependencia continua de
nuestra economía y el sistema financiero
y más importante que tenemos que hacer
en ese sentido es asegurarnos de que la
amenaza del presidente de la cámara
Kevin mccarthy del incumplimiento de la
deuda nacional está fuera de la mesa
y otra de las noticias de Estados Unidos
es que el First Republic Bank abrió este
lunes parte de sus sucursales Ya bajo
propiedad de jeepy Morgan este grupo
compró los depósitos y la mayoría de los
activos luego de que los reguladores de
Estados Unidos incautarán la entidad la
caída del férreepublic significa la
mayor quiebra bancaria desde 2008 y
forma parte de las consecuencias
desatadas por la caída del banco de
silicon Valley y del signature bank
desde Nueva York mamen sálanos amplia
los reguladores de Estados Unidos se
incautaron el Fer Republic van y hoy se
lo han vendido a GP Morgan Chase en lo
que se conoce ya como la segunda caída
bancaria más importante en la historia
de este país y después de varios
intentos fallidos de rescate con más de
229.000 millones de dólares en activo en
el momento de cierre del cierre esta
mañana el ferre Republic Bank ya ha
abierto sus 84 sucursales en ocho
estados del país bajo la propiedad bajo
la red de GP Morgan Chase Por qué se da
esta situación Pues bien porque en su
balance trimestral presentado por
ferrepública van mostraban que han
perdido un 40% de los depositantes y
todo es ese efecto dominó provocado por
la quiebra del silicon Qué pasó que
cuando se produjo la quiebra de este
banco de California muchos depositantes
decidieron sacar su dinero de los bancos
medianos y en otros donde son más
grandes en otros bancos más grandes y
que les ofrecían según ellos más
garantías Así que fue Republic Band ha
sido uno de los bancos medianos más
afectados y este ha sido el resultado de
hecho según banco famerica el 70% de sus
activos no estaban protegidos lo que
supone que estarían por encima de esos
250.000 dólares sin proteger que
permiten los reguladores de Estados
Unidos el presidente Joe biden ha dicho
en una conferencia en el día de hoy
desde la casa blanca que los
depositantes de ferrepublic Band pueden
estar tranquilos porque su dinero está
protegido ha celebrado la rápida
actuación de los reguladores de Estados
Unidos Les ha felicitado por facilitar
esta compra de ferrepublic Bank y aún
así ha pedido que haya una mayor
regulación un mayor control en los
medianos y grandes bancos de Estados
Unidos
en otras noticias el gobierno de Brasil
aumentará los esfuerzos para acabar con
la minería ilegal en la reserva indígena
y anomami esto después de que en la
noche del domingo uno por acción
policial acabará con la vida de cuatro
mineros ilegales además en otro punto de
la misma reserva el sábado un hombre de
la comunidad indígena murió y otros dos
resultaron heridos en enfrentamientos
con mineros que trabajan ilegalmente en
la zona después de que la tala y la
minería ilegal aumentaran durante el
mandato de Jair bolsonaro el presidente
Lula declaró tolerancia cero con la
minería ilegal y su gobierno asegura
haber expulsado al 80% de los 20.000
mineros que ocupaban la reserva indígena
los yanumami acusan a los Mineros de
contaminar sus aguas con mercurio y de
asesinar a personas de su comunidad
escuchemos las medidas que tomará el
gobierno
[Música]
el estado brasileño no retrocederá ante
la criminalidad las acciones como ya
dijo el ministro de Justicia serán
intensificadas
vamos a reforzar los equipos del
instituto brasileño de medio ambiente la
policía federal de caminos y policía
federal con las fuerzas armadas que son
fundamentales para el apoyo logístico y
todos los aspectos operativos para que
podamos dar una respuesta adecuada
y cerramos en Nueva York donde esta
noche se celebró la tradicional Met
galla una velada en que las celebridades
del mundo de la cultura la política la
moda welldeporte desfilan por la
alfombra roja del museo Metropolitano
con extravagantes atuendos marcados por
una temática que varía cada año en esta
ocasión los vestidos deben rendir
homenaje al diseñador Card larfield
icono creativo de Chanel y fallecido en
2019 la entrada a la ceremonia a la que
solo se accede por invitación de la
organizadora la editora jefe de la
revista boake and Winter vale cerca de
50 mil dólares la recaudación que el año
pasado fue de más de 17 millones de
dólares se destina al instituto del
traje de este museo neoyorquino en sus
pantallas pueden ver algunos de los
vestidos más destacados de esta Edición
de una gala que se celebró por primera
vez en 1948
llegamos así al final de esta emisión
sigan con más información
[Música]